Hi, Sandeep.
I.
Right. So I was going through.
Oh.
These uh release one requirements and I
thought I'll get some.
Some details from you on the item 19 ID
19 e-mail verification mandatory.
Yes.
So yeah,
I can talk you through that one e-mail
verification mandatory.
I think I'm told that this has been built
previously, but it was disabled.
So when we pick it up again,
we should first check if what code's
available and whether it's fit for.
Purpose uh and then if it is then we
enable it and test.
OK.
If it's not available or it's not present,
then we'll have to build that
Yeah.
functionality.
Now the functionality is that every time
I register before I can access my account
on.
E Save app using my username and password.
I need to activate by clicking on a link
You.
that is sent to me,
a unique link that's sent to me on a on
the e-mail.
That I've registered with.
So this link should have some sort of
expiry, maybe 24 hours or 72 hours.
We can figure that out,
but that link should be unique to me.
And once I've clicked on that link,
that activates my account and I can log
in.
So that ways we are verifying that you
actually own the e-mail address that you
have registered the account with.
OK.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
I think on the road map we should also
look for something that adds a captcha
when we are creating accounts.
It'll have to be a free service that we
can integrate with,
but that is for a future road map.
I I don't think we have any items for it.
Just flagging it here.
Mhm.
OK.
So basically the the flow is that you go
onto the site, you provide your,
you create your account,
you're providing your e-mail and on that
e-mail once the account is created it'll
send.
The verification link to that e-mail that
you used.
Yeah.
So you go into your e-mail and then click
on that to verify and then it it when you
click on that link it brings you back to
the E Save app, right?
Correct. Yep.
OK, so we have some.
What should we decide on some default
time for which this will be?
It's, yeah, I think 72 hours. Maybe.
Let's keep it as 72 hours.
OK.
Alright,
anything else around this requirement?
I think messaging.
We might need to show messaging if you're
trying to log in without activating the
account.
If the customer enters the right username
and password,
we should not log them in and show a
message saying.
Please activate your account first,
I think.
Yeah.
Yeah, that makes sense.
And when the user comes back to the E
Save app,
they will have to provide their password
here, right? For the first time,
it won't be like pre populated in any way.
Yes, yeah,
they'll have to provide their username
and password.
The activation link. Oh,
you mean when you click on the activation
Yeah.
link, what should happen? Oh yeah,
that that will bring you to a account
activation page and the the link.
They shouldn't need to enter their e-mail
or password to activate.
Their account.
It should just bring them to a page that
says your account has been activated.
OK, then how do they then?
Log in they just.
They will have to, yeah.
So once the account's activated,
they'll have to click on login in the
header and then log in after that using
their credentials.
So this time because their account's
activated, they won't see that.
Please activate your account message,
Yeah.
they just get logged in and go to the
dashboard.
OK.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
And the other parts like where they
provide the wrong password that I I guess
is already covered right in another.
Yeah, we'll, yeah,
we'll assume that's already covered.
OK.
okay yeah sounds good
Is it good? OK,
I've I've I switched on the transcription
so we can use that to create a ticket.
Let's see.
OK, perfect.
OK.
So we'll, yeah.
All right. Let me know when it's ready.
Thank you.
OK. Cheers. Bye.